Les femmes m'ont dit :
« Tu t'adapteras à cet endroit.
Tu trouveras ta place. »
On ne s'adressait plus à moi comme étant Teresa Njoroge.
Le nombre 415/11 était ma nouvelle identité
et j'ai vite appris que c'était le cas pour les autres femmes
avec qui je partageais les lieux.
Et je me suis adaptée à la vie à l'intérieur :
la nourriture de prison,
le langage de la prison,
la vie en prison.
La prison n'est certainement pas un monde féerique.
Ce que je n'ai pas vu venir,
ce sont les femmes et les enfants
avec qui nous purgions notre peine et partagions l'espace,
des femmes ayant été emprisonnées
pour des crimes du système,
une corruption nécessitant un dindon de la farce,
un bouc émissaire,
afin que la personne qui est responsable
soit libre.
Un système défaillant qui diabolise souvent les vulnérables,
les plus pauvres d'entre nous,
des gens qui ne peuvent pas payer de caution
ou de pots-de-vin.
Alors nous avons avancé.
Alors que j'écoutais toutes les histoires
de ces presque 700 femmes
au cours de cette année en prison,
j'ai réalisé que la criminalité
n'était pas ce qui avait mené ces femmes en prison,
la plupart de ces femmes,
loin de là.
Cela avait commencé avec un système éducatif
dont la distribution et la qualité ne sont pas égales pour tous ;
un manque d'opportunités économiques
qui pousse ces femmes à commettre des crimes mineurs pour survivre ;
le système de santé,
le système de justice sociale,
le système de justice pénale.
Si une de ces femmes,
pour la plupart issues d'un milieu pauvre,
passait à travers les mailles du filet
dans un système déjà défaillant,
le fond du gouffre est une prison,
un point c'est tout.
D'ici la fin de ma peine d'un an
dans la prison haute sécurité pour femmes de Langata,
j'étais ardemment convaincue
que je devais faire partie de la transformation
pour résoudre les injustices
dont j'avais été témoin
pour les femmes et les filles
coincées dans une porte tournante,
une vie à aller et venir en prison
du fait de la pauvreté.
Après ma libération,
j'ai lancé « Nouveau départ ».
Nouveau départ est une entreprise sociale
qui cherche à donner à ces femmes et ces filles
une deuxième chance.
Nous établissons des fondations pour elles.
Nous allons en prison, les formons,
leur offrons les compétences, les outils et le soutien
pour leur permettre d'être capables de changer leur état d'esprit,
leur comportement et leurs attitudes.
Nous établissons aussi des liens entre les prisons
et le secteur des entreprises --
des individus, des organisations
qui deviennent partenaires de Nouveau départ
pour nous permettre d'offrir un emploi,
un chez-soi,
des postes, des formations vocationnelles
pour ces femmes, ces filles,
ces garçons et ces hommes
à leur retour au sein de la société.
Je n'avais jamais pensé
qu'un jour,
je raconterais les histoires
des injustices si habituelles
au sein du système de justice pénale,
mais me voilà.
Chaque fois que je retourne en prison,
je me sens un peu comme chez moi,
mais c'est le considérable travail nécessaire
pour réaliser cette vision
qui me tient éveillée la nuit,
reliant les points jusqu'à la Louisiane,
qui est présumée être la capitale mondiale de l'incarcération,
emmenant avec moi les histoires
de centaines de femmes
que j'ai rencontrées dans des prisons.
Certaines d'entre elles embrassent maintenant leur seconde chance
et d'autres sont toujours sur ce chemin dans le parcours de leur vie.
J'incarne une phrase
de la grande Maya Angelou :
« Je viens seule,
mais j'en représente 10 000. »
(Applaudissements)
Mon histoire est singulière,
mais imaginez avec moi
les millions de personnes
emprisonnées aujourd'hui,
aspirant à la liberté.
Trois ans après ma condamnation
et deux ans après ma libération,
j'ai été acquittée par la cour d'appel
de tout acte répréhensible.
(Applaudissements)
A la même période,
j'ai été bénie par l'arrivée de mon fils
que j'ai appelé Uhuru,
ce qui dans mon dialecte signifie « liberté ».
(Applaudissements)
Car j'avais enfin acquis cette liberté
que j'avais si longtemps désirée.
Je viens seule,
mais j'en représente 10 000,
encouragée par l'espoir coriace
que des milliers d'entre nous se sont réunis
pour réformer et transformer le système de justice pénale,
encouragée par le fait que nous faisons notre travail
comme nous sommes censés le faire.
Laissez-nous le faire
sans excuses.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)